une vallis une valise plantes
d'expérience d'une année des changes
j'ouvre les cinq sens pour voir à notre
paysage pour sentir les vignes pour
entendre les bruits d'une huile et pour
goûter les spécialités souffre l'esprit
mais la chose la plus importante est de
souffrir sma même pour s'adapter et
santé créé un échange a principalement
trois poles le premier repas les langues
mystique on apprend on améliore une
longue et ont la maîtrise
le deuxième volet social on a mis dans
une famille d'accueil
on a des amis et des loisirs et le
troisième palais culturel une autre
culture une autre religion d'autres
coutumes d'autres traditions etc
c'est moi c'est moi pour les changes je
suis ambitieuse et sans crainte
je suis ouverte à tout et j'adore le
valais je suis toujours à l'heure et
j'aime rire pendant mon temps libre je
pratique de l'alpinisme
je fais de la musique et je cuisine
j'habite proches d'appenzell à la
campagne avec l'appui en abondance la
ville n'est pas la campagne
le dépassement dans une ville comme si
j'habitais pendant une année et beaucoup
plus facile et aussi plus écologique
par contre dans une ville s'appuie
énormément et il ne fait jamais nuit on
est toujours entouré des bruits de plus
je me suis sentie surveillé par les
voisins
au début j'ai quitté ma famille mes
animaux et mes amis
mais à la fin j'ai dû quitter en
environnement que j'ai appris à aimer il
famille d'accueil qui est devenue une
deuxième famille j'ai aussi dû quitter
une certaine liberté de la ville les
langes à la fin était en même temps de
l'an de bonheur et de tristesse et le
français apprendre une langue ça prend
du temps et c'est difficile je me sente
perdu est désespérée et j'étais souvent
fatigués après une année la langue n'est
plus une barrière et je suis presque bi
langues
au début je comprenne enviro 5%
par contre à la fin presque 100% pendant
mon échange a été l'école l'élément
principal
je faisais tout autour d'elle je n'avais
pas de vacances je devais didier plus
que d'habitude pour me préparer au cours
je lisais les livres en avance et je
relis c'est tout et on ne doit pas
oublier que tout prend plus de temps que
d'habitude
la classe et l'aspect principal à
l'école heureusement ma classe et des
très ouverte
elle m'a toujours aidé par exemple quand
j'avais besoin de notes afin de les
copier car je n'arrivais pas dans chaque
proche de suivre le professeur je me
suis aussi engagé pour le climat avec
une copine j'ai écrit est aussi pour
participer au concours lancé par la
ville de sion on pouvait imaginer un
projet pour améliorer le climat dans la
ville de sion et le décrire dans un
dossier le juré de la ville de sion a
retenu ensuite les trois meilleurs de
tous et ensuite choisi les deux
meilleurs projets qui vont être mises en
route notre projection dans la nuit et
un autre projet ont été les deux
gagnants
j'ai vécu une année dans une famille
d'accueil
ma famille me faisais la vie facile elle
m'a toujours dit que j'étais la
bienvenue et elle m'a toujours soutenu
avec leurs amis qui sont en crue civ
nous sommes au fait des activités et
nous allons passer de bonnes soirées
ensemble en discutant sur dieu et le
monde
ma soeur d'accueil m'a dit un jour que
j'étais russe perd ma peau est si claire
est la sienne et foncez mme affret
famille je ne l'est pas oublié elle est
fière de moi et elle a aussi eu
confiance en moi sinon je n'aurais pas
pu faire cet échange j'ai aussi
continuer mes loisirs en crampons en ce
qu'ils ont et en faisant peau de phoque
j'ai découvert le valais d'une autre
côté les changements aussi permis
d'essayer l'initiation de glace et le
temps ville avec le vélo j'ai fait
connaissance avec le valais durant une
année et il ya des différences entre le
valais et la peine celle par exemple le
vent chez vous et la bière genou la
médiation est toujours fabuleuse mais la
pluie m'a manqué et le paysage chez vous
il y avait autre il y a des autres
montagnes chez nous des collines le
cliché que les valets samson cros et les
appenzellois son petit et en même temps
frais et fo
je connais des vallées sans fils au
petit mais j'ai vu il n'ya pas longtemps
une statistique du militaire suisse est
dans la moyenne de la taille
les valaisans sont le plus grand de
toute la suisse alors faites et
s'échange car on ne peut rien perdre ce
mot gagner quand on me demandait de ce
que je faisais la plupart disent ensuite
j'aurais aussi voulu faire un échange
mais je ne voulais pas quitter ma
famille mon petit copain et cetera
non ne vous laissez pas stoppé par
décider
vous vivez seulement une fois et vous
devez profiter de chaque chance moi moi
j'aimerais tout de suite refaire mon
année des changes car je faisais des
expériences pour toute la vie et l'année
m'a rendu plus mûr jeu mais maintenant
dans mon coffre tout ce que j'ai appris
tous les moments vécus soit rôle soit
difficile une langue que j'ai appris à
maîtriser et beaucoup beaucoup plus
balai crabbe dans mon coeur
[Applaudissements]